hablamos de economía en france 24 por
ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
en esta edición hablamos del comercio
mundial tras la guerra y dos años de
pandemia así es que después de estos dos
años la organización mundial del
comercio brindo recientemente sus
perspectivas para el comercio mundial y
no son nada positivas en el volumen del
comercio de mercancías crecerá un 3% en
2022 frente al 4,7 por ciento que se
proyectaba en octubre del año pasado
cuando la guerra no estaba en el radar
el organismo cita los confinamientos
impuestos en china para controlar los
brotes de kobe 19 estos confinamientos
en shanghai donde muchas multinacionales
tienen su sede y también se ubica el
mayor puerto de china incide
directamente en américa latina pero por
qué es tan importante lo que pasa en
china para la región se lo preguntamos a
patricio giusto él es director del
observatorio sino argentino y docente
del posgrado sobre china contemporánea
de la universidad católica de argentina
y esto nos dijo
bueno china es el primer socio comercial
prácticamente de todos los países de
sudamérica y de gran parte de
centroamérica también creo que tenemos
la excepción de colombia de china del
segundo tercer socio según el periodo
del año pero ya es el primer socio de
brasilia es el primer socio argentina de
chile de uruguay de perú etcétera de
venezuela porque con distintas distintos
productos que son importantes en cada
caso pero al fin y al cabo en términos
comerciales está muy consolidada como el
primer socio china y en ascenso y además
como una gran fuente de inversiones y de
finanzas para la región superando
incluso a los eeuu en algunas categorías
y otros países por ejemplo para citarse
algunos casos hay menor demanda de cobre
hay menor demanda de poroto de soja hay
menor demanda de mineral de hierro que
esto tiene que ver por la lento el
crecimiento menor al esperado en china
si el año que viene para el año que
viene que las proyecciones son de 55
pero ya estamos hablando de que esto es
muy poco realista y vamos a estar
probablemente cerca de un 44.5 eso va a
tener un impacto muy
porque es que en algunos países los
efectos económicos ya se comienzan a
evidenciar y sobre todo por el aumento
de los precios la inflación que hay
avenida en alza desde mediados del año
pasado por los problemas en la cadena de
suministro y luego el aumento de los
precios de la energía tocan ahora las
puertas de américa latina donde muchos
bancos centrales están aumentando los
tipos de interés para intentar frenarla
a nuestro invitado le preguntamos cuál
será el efecto inmediato además de la
inflación que ya es un problema serio
para varios países de la región y esto
dijo tuvieron lo has dicho el efecto
inflacionario es inmediato sobre todo
cuando en con respecto a ciertos
productos que nosotros importamos y que
somos muy dependientes y que no los
podemos reemplazar
y por otra parte el otro efecto que es
muy fuerte es menos divisas cuando hay
menos exportaciones e ingresan menos
dólares a las arcas de los bancos
centrales entonces hay menos margen para
la política monetaria
aumentan los déficit comerciales y eso
hay que financiarlo de alguna forma es
aumentar la deuda
algunos sectores cobrar más impuestos es
otra de las soluciones que obviamente
siempre están a mano pero como sea eso
hay que sufrirlo de alguna forma y te
repito hay países como el caso de la
argentina que ya están en una situación
muy crítica sin ningún margen de
maniobra entonces ahí hay que prestar
mucho la atención para ver cómo
evoluciona la situación se tenía que
prestemos también atención a perú que
está teniendo una gran inestabilidad
política y va a ser muy afectado
seguramente también la olade argentina y
perú pero ya son muchos más los que
sentimos estos efectos y sin duda el
comercio mundial la dependencia
energética y los alimentos se ven
afectados en este contexto aprovechamos
esta entrevista con patricio para
preguntarle también cómo sería el
comercio postguerra y post pandemia y
asimismo cuáles serán los cambios más
relevantes en materia económica luego de
todas estas crisis que se están juntando
escuchamos bueno yo creo que
lamentablemente va a haber varios
retrocesos por ejemplo vamos a ir un
mundo donde la globalización del cual la
veníamos consiguiendo va a entrar en
crisis por esta nueva disputa este nuevo
clima de guerra fría eso en términos
geopolíticos y en ese sentido en lo
económico que va a pasar los países van
a entender a buscar más autosuficiencia
que buscar autosuficiencia tratar de
depender lo menos posible de insumos o
productos críticos del exterior hay unos
países que tienen margen para hacerlo
otros no china es un caso china va a
tener que seguir comprando muchos
alimentos y mucha anarquía no en el caso
de algunos países de latinoamérica pasa
algo similar justamente con el tema
energético lo que va a haber me parece
que la parte positiva quizás una
renovada mirada a lo regional a la
integración regional en la que américa a
tratar de mejorar las relaciones
comerciales intrazona en los distintos
bloques yo creo que eso es algo positivo
pero lo negativo en términos de los
flujos generales del comercio global
probablemente tengamos restricciones
tengamos menos comercio pero en esa
búsqueda autosuficiencia por ahí surgen
oportunidades y surgen acuerdos
interesantes sobre todo escala regional
lo estamos viendo en europa con el tema
del gas
vamos a ver probablemente en
latinoamérica con con otras cuestiones
me parece que eso es la tendencia de lo
que se viene próximamente jorge a usted
ya nuestro invitado muchas gracias
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]